here's glennado just as emily mentioned
for start of the season they're
the
692 era mainly because of that last
start in oakland where he gave up eight
earned runs
otto's still learning at the major
league level
two a pitch from otto and this one
lifted high in the air out to right
field that'll be playable
for dj peters one away
and he hits his ball sharply to third
base and right there ford hernandez
so the line out is the second out of the
inning
2-2 pitch and a little tapper right back
to otto
they'll run it halfway to first
underhanded over there and it's a one
two three first inning of the rookie
looked very good he's gonna be
right-handed luis garcia on the mound
for your houston astros from valdez was
scheduled to be the starter he is
reported to have a cut on his index
finger and has been scratched therefore
luis garcia will take his spot
[Applause]
ground ball hits softly right side into
the shift fielded by correa to his left
he throws to first in time
this ball popped up julie guriel and
foul territory will retire isaiah kinder
philippa
on the ground gloved by yuli guriel
he'll take it to the bag himself a one
two three start for both glen otto and
luis garcia
a swing and a miss here by guriel on the
auto slider so glen otto records his
first strikeout
so one strike pitch now to tucker and
that one on the ground out into short
right field and the throw hustled over
the first in time to get tucker
on the ground diving stopped by yani
hernandez and safe at second base carlos
correa meyers had a good night last
night for houston and he taps this one
over the mound charge again from
shortstop is kind of fluffy so the first
night in time now the rangers
may want to take a look at this
the astros will have stranded two
there's the signal it isn't out
ground ball right at the third baseman
bregman he's up with it throws across in
time
lines one into right center field
that'll be down for a hit who wants it
siri and tucker were kind of looking at
each other and trying to go to second is
calhoun not a good idea siri throws out
the runner calhoun trying to stretch a
single into a double
we're gonna get a replay
did he nail the runner look at him i
don't know
he may have missed him that call is
gonna stand he go and that brings up the
catcher joel pozo and the pitch to poso
poke to the right side right behind
solac it rolls slowly into right field
charged by tucker he fires to third and
solak dives safely into third ahead of
the throw rangers now have minute first
and third with two outs for brock holt
on the ground altuve to his right makes
the play
[Applause]
this one down to third base white two
yani hernandez maldonado not exactly
busting it down the line he's an easy
out
first pitch dow tuve he rips one to left
center field but tavares has a beat on
it to his right he drops to a knee and
makes the catches it has some sinking
action top spin on it
0-2
and he swings and misses
[Applause]
pops this one pretty well to left field
is myers
back pedals a couple steps in left and
makes the catch for out number one
drives this one to right field tucker
back about five steps and makes the
catch loping backwards so with two outs
here in the bottom of the third rangers
have runners at first and second for dj
peters
got him
went back to the fastball and
now just 9 10 and ops which is fifth in
the american league as he drills one
down the right field line that is headed
to the corner cut off there by dj peters
that will keep yulie from having a
chance to score astros in business
second and third nobody out
correa drives one deep center field all
the way back to barris forget about it
three run jack carlos correa the astros
out in front three to nothing on
correa's 23rd home run of the year
starting to make mistakes with that
slider a slider that got too much of the
play to tucker bond of being a double
and that slider i mean that was center
cut for carlos correa back to back to
back walks and bregman gets a shot now
with his bases jacked
and he hits this one down the left field
line that's going to be a base hit
chasing it down as calhoun scoring meyer
scoring maldonado it's a two-run single
for bregman and it's 5-0
the ninth batter of the inning now
jordan alvarez
jordan drills one to right field that'll
be over the head of dj peterson off the
wall altuve can walk home bregman the
third yard on alvarez scorches a double
to right it is six nothing astros six
runs ties the astros most runs in one
inning this year there's only one out
for guriel
there's a looper into shallow center
that's a base hit scoring is bregman his
76th rbi and it's seven to nothing and
that's the most runs the astros have
scored in one inning this year
[Applause]
altuve drills one to left and that ball
be over the willy calhoun's head
maldonado racing to third and now two
minutes second baldy is faster too with
those new look socks and their two men
in scoring position with nobody out for
bregman he drove in two with a single in
the
rounds it up the middle and throw for a
base hit maldonado scores altuve around
third and coming home the throw to the
plate by tavares not nearly in time
altuve scores standing up bregman drives
in two more he has four rbis tonight the
astros lead it nine nothing
[Applause]
and he hits this one sharply to second
base it'll get a run home but a 4-3 put
out
chad mccormick will get his first at bat
chaz mccormick drives one high and deep
to left field calhoun all the way back
on
jazz mccormick a two-run home run gives
the astros double figures tonight it's
11-1
a big smile from chaz it's been a minute
how about this rocket from the former
sugarland skeeter jake myers one hops
one over the wall that'll be an rbi
double
let carlos correa trot home that makes
it 12-1
six of eight for strike so far
and there you go ball game over
josh james a one two three ninth inning
[Applause]
you